in this scene from 2021's mortal kombat
melina unhinges her jaw to show off her
famous teeth during a fight scene
that disgusting oozing and cracking you
here is actually two layers of
vegetables cracked
and snapped all by a layer of wet gravel
handled just the right way by the film's
foley artist
the sound team behind mortal kombat went
above and beyond for the movie's
over-the-top fights and gore
and every sound maid had to follow the
action on screen
while living up to the gruesome standard
fans expected
warning spoilers for mortal kombat ahead
and this video is gory so maybe don't
watch around children
mortal kombat may be the goriest film
i've ever worked on
to make all that gore believable the
team needed everything to sound as
organic as possible
they focused on capturing audio from
real objects
so nothing was overly processed and
while the artist used some audio from a
digital library
most of the sonic landscape was created
with original sounds
the very very few digital sounds in the
in the
in the film it's all very fully analog
orientated
creating new sounds was crucial for the
mortal kombat characters
as they are known for their unique armor
and weapons
take that moment we showed you earlier
john hinging
isn't something you'd easily find
pre-recorded so the foley team created
it themselves
first foley artist adrian medhurst knew
he needed a crunch to match the flesh
separating the capsicum
can add a little bit of a hollow sound
to it like it's as if it's in a jaw
but medhurst also wanted to get an ooze
at the same time
so we turn to wet gravel and just moving
that and grinding it in my hand gives a
nice little
texture and depending on if you cuff
your hands a little bit you can get a
little bit of a hollow
sound like it would be in the mouth sort
of thing play these all together and you
get
these sounds needed to live up to the
game's trademark moves
which involve unusual weapons beyond
typical swordplay
kung lao's hat required a plate and
metal strips to get the right weight
and speed depending on how you hold it
you can get different
sounds out of it it could ring more or
less and with your nails you could get
more of a
shimmery sound but the finishing touches
came from sound designer robert mckenzie
who decided to scrape a symbol with a
knife and apply distortions like a
doppler effect
which makes it sound like this the sound
is
passing by us very quickly
[Music]
these distinctive weapons also meant
distinctive kills
many which involved multiple body parts
take this mess created when kung lao
splits natara in half
the scene involves cutting through flesh
guts and bone
for the flesh medhar started with a pile
of wet noodles
sometimes i might start with pasta raw
even wet newspaper and just
think of different things to add into
the mix
but he still needed more squish so we
added some grapefruit and tomatoes
and for the bone splitting good old
celery and capsicum
even typical sounds like punches had to
be reimagined for characters like jax
who has giant metal arms this moment
where he repeatedly punches riko
required trial and error
especially because those punches drew
blood
first meadows tried punching grapefruit
but just to get a bit more weight i
tried using the melon
he found he needed to do more than hit
the melon with his hands for a sharper
break
so i grabbed the hammer and tried to
smash the melon
and in the most gruesome moments they
had to really break down every aspect of
a kill
i think the hardest thing about it is
providing enough
variation to the different types of gore
so artists looked at the movement and
viscosity of blood
or body parts to help them choose their
props the props is almost like
instruments and they sort of
have to figure out what notes they can
play so sometimes i'm picking them up
and tapping them in them
take this moment where kano rips
reptile's heart out of his chest
a move he's known for in the game like
with natara's death medhurst needed a
flesh ripping
sound he tried rubbing a grapefruit
against cabbage
but found it too squeaky
so he tore into the cabbage himself
but he did need the grapefruit to
capture squirts of blood coming out of
the heart
they got nice juice to them which can be
quite bloody
and to make it really over the top he
found dipping the grapefruit in water
added to the gross out factor it's not
as thick as blood but
um it just helps add a bit of extra
liquid
now compare that to the blood that
bursts out of reiko's head after jack
smashes it
to account for the brain bits this
bloody hit had to sound chunkier
so medhurst went back to the noodles and
newspaper used for the body split
it's just handy to have a big pile of
chopped up sort of bits and pieces
this explosion of blood and guts was so
big it required a boot stomp to add an
audible impact
these sounds created a fully gruesome
symphony once they were layered together
we were processing a few of the sounds
to make them sound a little bit
bigger and grittier beefy low end kind
of processes
so just to give the sounds a bit more
roundness and depth and power
the final pieces of the puzzle came from
sound designers like james ashton
they added their own unexpected touches
like the sound of a slithering octopus
for a little more slime
that's the fun part about it is the
experimentation and
finding the sounds that really bring the
picture to life